il y a un vieux dicton baudis qui dit
qu'il n'y a rien de constant si ce n'est
que le changement est aujourd'hui cela
ne serait être plus vrai
au moment où je vous parle nos sociétés
vivent des transformations économiques
fondamentales dont on ne peut ignorer le
simple revers de la main
ces transformations d'abord
technologiques sont passionnantes mais
surtout très puissante et exige que l'on
prenne action dès maintenant sans quoi
il sera trop tard
je parle évidemment de l'avènement des
plateaux d'économie collaborative ou de
partage peu importe comme on les appelle
l'avènement de ces plateformes ont un
impact sur l'ensemble des économies
actuelle allant de l'hôtellerie à la
mobilité de la finance jusqu'à la
restauration en touchant même les arts
et la culture et ne laisse personne
indifférent et elles sont fondamentales
l'ensemble des paradigmes économiques
actuelles se trouve à être changé
mais en fait il faut comprendre c'est
que l'économie collaborative transpose
dans le monde numérique des pratiques
commerciales qui sont ancestrales mais
en permettant et en facilitant les
échanges de biens services de talent et
le tout avec une mise à l'échelle plus
grande
mais qu'est-ce l'économie collaborative
qu'entends je suis jetée dans la pièce
en soit l'économie collaborative repose
sur quatre critères fondamentaux qui
ensemble sont ilani l'érable à savoir
indissociables
le premier critère denis conus
collaborative c'est l'utilisation de la
capacité qui sont excédentaires soient
l'optimisation d'un bien par exemple je
possède un véhicule je vais m je vais me
mettre mon véhicule à louer sur une
place de marché pour optimiser sa
capacité parce qu'on sait très bien que
96 % du temps nos véhicules sont
stationnés
le deuxième critère est le partage
plutôt que la possession bon ça sonne
comme une thèse marxiste mais est censé
mais ce n'est que l'optimisation d'un
bien matériel je reprends l'exemple du
véhicule l'idée est ici pourquoi
pourquoi devrais-je posséder un véhicule
si je peux en louer un sur diverses
plateformes
le troisième critère c'est la
multiplicité des fonctions ici il s'agit
de rabaisser les barrières à l'entrée
dans différents marchés pour permettre à
tout et chacun une pleine utilisation de
son temps et de ses talents le jour je
peux être un entrepreneur un professeur
ou un avocat et le soir je te m'a
souvent derrière un volant et conduire
des gens travers différentes plateformes
le quatrième critère qui est selon moi
le plus important c'est la
dématérialisation des intermédiaires
soit de désaisonnaliser les échanges
essentiellement il s'agit d'enlever les
tiers partis inutile dans une
transaction reprenons l'exemple du
véhicule jadis il fallait absolument
aller dans des centres qui veut qu'il ne
faisait que ça de la location automobile
maintenant avec un téléphone j'ai accès
à une myriade de véhicules
bon en entendent parler vraiment on se
trouve à l'apogée du développement
économique mais la réalité n'est pas
comme tel en fait comme toute innovation
l'avènement de l'économie de partage
apporte son lot de perturbations et ces
perturbations se font sentir à
différents niveaux d'abord au niveau
économique où on observe une
centralisation toujours croissante des
richesses générées et ce à travers le 1%
cette centralisation en fait est
exacerbée par le faible coût de
déploiement de ces plateformes
un second fléau qui a mené par toutes
ces transformations
c'est essentiellement la gestion
mercantile des données où on voit une
centralisation nous ne sommes plus les
utilisateurs non devient les produits de
ces applications
nous donner sont à leur pied de tous
bords tous côtés et centrer sans même
qu'on en bénéfices en bénéficient des
retombées
un autre problème qui est générée c'est
une exploitation
prédatrice des travailleurs sous forme
d'un incident d'appauvrissement
perpétuelle
face à ces chambardements économique il
faut pas se leurrer ces phénomènes sont
là pour rester il faut prendre un peu de
recul parce que on peut y répondre
en fait la thèse que j'avance et que en
combinant la coopération qui est
l'établissement d'une gestion
démocratique et la décentralisation
ci est une technologie permettant de
gérer les données de manière plus
transversale on peut créer des
alternatives qui sont émancipatrice à
savoir désirable viable est faisable le
tout sur des assises de justice absolue
et d'équité irréversible
donc quand on parle de coopération on
imagine souvent leurs six colloques dans
un appartement qui décide de se partir
une boutique de vêtements faits en
chambre mais le coopérative votre bien
au dos et au québec plus qu'ailleurs on
le sait très bien alors qu'une fois
moins environ un quart de la population
canadienne on regroupe un tiers des
coopératives avec des fleurons comme
desjardins
solio agropur et bien plus
face à l'avènement de tous ces
transformations économiques le modèle
coopératif
lui aussi s'est adapté en fait on voit
l'émergence de ce qu'on appelle des
plates formes coopératives fois des
coopératives numériques qui sont
essentiellement des copains qui sont
possédés par les utilisateurs
à l'instant des coopératives
traditionnels
les coopératives de plateformes ont
d'abord la mutualisation des ressources
comme premier critère de fondation c'est
à dire on partage les actifs
on a ensuite une gouvernance
démocratique le fameux un membre un vote
qui s'applique à travers la plateforme
ensuite on à la redistribution des
richesses
et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
ristourne pour finalement compléter le
tout avec la responsabilisation des
membres
ce faisant on permet de créer et
coopératives dans le monde numérique en
octroyant plus de droits aux
utilisateurs
c'est le cas de free and fair bienne be
qui est une alternative émancipatrice à
un bien de ville à l'instar de la
seconde fut bien le bee est une
application qui permet des bois des
voyages de courte de durée tout en étant
soucieuse des résidents et des
communautés locales
puisqu'il s'agit d'une coopérative elle
s'approprie les mécanismes de
gouvernance traditionnels dont le vote
nominal ainsi les hôtes peuvent choisir
la tarification ou encore voter sur une
facturation qui est intelligible
puisque qu'une coopérative il est en
quelque sorte décentralisée l'ensemble
des membres ont des pouvoirs égaux et
cette logique en fait s'applique aussi à
la technologie blu che ou entre chevron
france mais entre la théologie blogging
ou la chaîne de blocs en français
quand on pense à la blague chaîne on
pense
incontestablement hobbit poigne qui est
cette fille de monique qui permet de 30
g de la valeur sans passer par des
espions financières traditionnelles
mais la bloque chain et la technologie
qui sous-tend le bitcoin et qui impacte
davantage nos vie socio-économique
la blocs chine est en fait un réseau
distribué maintenu par des ordinateurs
participants il s'agit d'une base de
données qui stocke dans un registre
public qui possède quoi et qui
transigent quoi et ce à travers le temps
c'est une infrastructure qui est
inviolable et qui peut s'appliquer comme
je l'aï mentionné à différentes économie
numérique
en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que le web 1.0 nous a permis de
communiquer le web 2.0 nous a permis
d'interroger mais avec la blood chaîne
le web 3.0 permet de se faire confiance
et l'application de la blood chaînes
comme un cadastre numérique aux
coopératives permet aux coopératives en
fait de se développer davantage ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant parce qu'il y
avait des freins à l'expansion
les principes fondateurs de la chaîne de
blogs sont un peu comme la coopérative
une gestion transparente c'est à dire
que tous les utilisateurs participants
auront accès à ce qui se passe ensuite
on parle d'un réseau qui est par
ailleurs maintenue ici par des
ordinateurs participants peu importe
l'algorithme utilisé pour la
confirmation des transactions on parle
d'un protocole conseil consensuelle
parce que tout est défini dans un
contrat intelligent qui la série de
lignes de code définit l'entente
contractuelle immuable entre
utilisateurs et ça a piqué une
coopérative c'est révolutionnaire
c'est le code de evra évoque une
alternative à hubert il s'agit d'une
plateforme de livraison et de
covoiturage entièrement décentralisé
en franchisant sa technologie à des
entreprises dont des coopérations elle
permet à des communautés de chauffeurs
de se réapproprier les moyens de
production est de posséder eux mêmes
leurs services de mobilité bon je ne
suis pas en train de faire l'apologie de
la blog shane comme la thèse
libertarienne en attestant que la blood
chaîne à elle seule est la solution à
tous les maux économiques
évidemment cela ne fait que créer un peu
un deep techno féodal ce que j'avance en
fait ce que l'agglo chain juxtaposés un
modèle coopératif permet de renverser
les dictateurs qui sont imposés par les
plateformes collaboratives actuelle on
peut ainsi reprendre au plus ainsi voir
émerger une révolution économique et
reprendre le pouvoir un clic à la fois
ce qui bloquait anciennement les
coopératives de se développer peut
maintenant être aimé c'est par la chaîne
de blog car la chaîne de blocs pas des
pouvoirs qui sont beaucoup plus grands
et qui peuvent connaître une mise à
l'échelle qui est incontournable donc
l'autre on additionne la modèle
coopératif à une technologie
décentralisée on a ce qu'on appelle une
organisation autonome décentralisée ou
du moins l'objectif de nos régions
autonomes décentralisée qui est vraiment
cet écosystème qui met nu par lui-même
de manière autonome ainsi on peut avoir
une gestion qui est local mais avoir des
visées qui sont globales
faire bien faire bien billets et va nous
prouve qu'il est possible de
déconstruire les ordonnances imposé et
de coups construire ensemble le futur de
nos économies bien que airbnb et hubert
sur les arbres qui cachent la forêt les
pronostics de l'économie collaboratives
sont illimitées ils savent donc
contre-productif de rechuter allègrement
en fait ces chambardements économique
car ceux ci sont là pour rester en fait
il faut embrasser cette innovation est
écrit nos propres alternative
sans quoi on est en quelque sorte
contraint de subir l'innovation de
l'extérieur on imagine trop souvent la
révolution numérique comme une chose qui
est irréalisable contenu du pouvoir et
de l'influencé géant du web or je crois
que cette révolution elle est déjà
enclenché et qui existe des liens qui
sont en train de métamorphoser
l'ensemble de nos interactions sociales
et économiques
malgré le vertige et le sentiment
d'impuissance qui nous habite face à la
libéralisation de l'économie ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'il est
maintenant possible de redorer le blason
des pratiques commerciales qui sont
jurassique comme l'économie
collaborative comme toute révolution
celle ci réclame la transformation de
nos consciences individuelles et
collectives
car oui tout et tout est possible
maintenant et chats à chaque instant les
idées novatrices se multiplient en
juxtaposant ou en combinant le modèle
coopératif à la décentralisation on
permet de créer ce qu'il était
impossible de faire avant
l'adoption elle seule ne savent pas
grand chose car il s'agit d'un
instrument et pour jouer de cet
instrument il lui faut un musicien qui
soit assez doué le modèle coopératif qui
a été éprouvée depuis des décennies
dont ils nous imposent de viser la
démocratisation comme philosophie
la coopération comme suit historique la
localisation comme terrains
d'intervention
la décentralisation comme technologie et
la révolution comme cadre
d'interprétation policiers dans une
vision constante évolution de notre
société
car avec nos téléphones à la main tout
devient possible maintenant ozon ou
réunion nous a tous car seul on va
peut-être plus vite mais ensemble on va
beaucoup plus loin merci
[Applaudissements]